Luke dominate here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're doing
the polished aluminum ball challenge
[Music]
well me and Nate here we're gonna go
into the supermarket and we got to buy a
bunch of tinfoil cuz we are going to try
to make some super crazy polish Japanese
tin foil balls now if you have no clue
what I'm talking about
check this out so apparently the hottest
new thing in Japan is taking balls of
aluminum foil and beating them until
they're round and super shiny and
polished and even though it's really
pointless it looks kind of cool and I'm
gonna give it a try and see if I could
do it too so you get the heavy duty
stuff I have no clue is this a lot is
this enough you think okay once you put
it in the car buddy now hearing that the
Japanese are into super polishing
aluminum foil balls isn't super
surprising I lived in southern Japan for
two years and man I just love the
Japanese people and this totally sounds
like something kids over there could get
into it's a lot better than eating Tide
Pods but anyway we're gonna try this out
and see how easy or hard it is to do I
have no idea if this takes hours or
weeks or months or what but we're gonna
give it a go aren't we Nathan alright
well guys we don't know what we're doing
but we're excited to do it so we're
going to start making tinfoil balls you
guys ready yeah I have no idea how much
kids well this takes but I figure we
should start small and start compressing
it as we go instead of just making a
ball and then compressing it so let's
see what happens
don't blow this up I guess and make it
as tight as you can you don't make them
all I saw kids with hammers I'm gonna
get some hammers oh yeah you know I have
an anvil outside why am I doing this on
the kitchen table should we go to the
anvil let's go all right so this is my
blacksmithing Forge in case you didn't
know I do some blacksmithing videos go
for it Nathan hit that thing you just
hold it and you just hit the side come
in handy yeah all right got a tight
little ball right there look at this
kind of bounces okay
yeah I think I got an idea oh there we
go slowly but surely it's getting a
little bigger just add layers at a time
yeah I roll here yeah wrap it into tin
foil
just do a small piece wrap it in some
tin foil and then roll it guys we're
starting to get rained on it's getting
wet on here let's go take this into the
kitchen see if we can do this on the
table now now important part of doing
this is you've got to wear your tin foil
hat so you tube can't read your thoughts
and D monetize my videos it's true just
gets in here but maybe if we cut the tin
foil into little squares we can add it
one layer at a time and it'll help us
build the ball up smoothly so we don't
have to do less working and shaping it
[Music]
can you read my baby thoughts yeah
neither can the FBI well that's not too
shabby let's keep growing this thing see
how big we can get it well that looks
pretty cool so far it's really hard and
heavy for a ball of aluminum foil they
bake it took this out oh Henry than I
expected
yeah it's pretty cool huh yeah well my
wife wasn't a super huge fan to be
banging on the kitchen table so they
kicked me out and I'm here at the
workbench but I need to clean this thing
off got a couple projects sitting out
here so we're gonna clean this up and
keep working on our tinfoil ball
[Music]
[Music]
check that out guys that is three rolls
of aluminum foil 110 square feet and
it's heavy and it's this that it's this
is hard I mean there is not a lot of
give in this thing man it is compressed
and it's already pretty darn around so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take this
flattening hammer and I'm gonna try to
just get some of the ridges and
imperfections out of it and just make it
as perfectly round as possible it's
pretty darn close to there and look at
that thing after I get it completely
round and I got to start polishing this
thing I'm not even quite sure how I'm
gonna do that but it's gonna be crazy
looks pretty darn good except for this
little flappy bit the edge of the last
layer always has a little bit of a
flabby bit I'm not quite sure how to get
rid of that so I'm gonna try something
dramatic I'm gonna try melting the edge
a little bit but I don't want to do it
on this so I made this little test ball
right here and I'm gonna try melting the
edge of the flappy bit down with it with
a torch and see if that helps
consolidate it a little bit
yeah I don't know if I call that an
improvement that just looks ugly all
right so now I've got it round I need to
polish it so I'm gonna start gentle and
experiment a little bit I've got a
buffing wheel attachment to my drill and
I've got some buffing chalk here
[Music]
well that's actually kind of working
well this is polishing up nicely but
it's taking off little bits of aluminum
as they go and so I'm really hoping I
don't unravel the whole ball polishing
this thing well it's looking pretty good
but I'm gonna try putting this mag and
aluminum polish on it and see if that
doesn't help take it to just the next
level here
[Music]
once you get the ball this polished you
need something extra soft to put a final
layer of polish on it in this instance
I'm gonna use a baby because they're
very soft look at that oh yeah that is
pretty darn shiny and I can see my
reflection in it but there's all the
little wrinkles and textures in the
surface and I wasn't able to get those
out I think it has to do with the way I
built the ball by doing it one layer at
a time really slowly it made it nice and
round and very hard and dense but the
more I polished it the more I just strip
off layers I think if I were to just
crinkle the ball up I might be able to
get it more polished like I've seen
online that cool well guys this was a
fun little adventure and making this
ball took me about six hours so not
exactly a quick project but I want to
put it in perspective here this right
here is an entire roll of aluminum foil
this right here is three rolls this is a
hundred and ten square feet of aluminum
foil and it weighs a bit it's it's
really heavy it's three times heavier
than this ball over here it's crazy and
I can actually see my reflection in this
ball it's crazy how polished it is it's
a little wrinkled on its surface and I
wish I could have taken that off but you
know it is so polished and it is really
round and it is very hard this is one of
the coolest pointless things I've ever
done well this was actually a lot more
fun than I expected we had a good time
doing this didn't we guys so if you guys
would like to try this go ahead do your
own aluminum ball polishing challenge
and post pictures of your product on our
Facebook page I'd love to see what you
guys can do with this this is a fun
little challenge and a great little
introduction into polishing and metal
work but if you guys would like to see
more of our videos we've got
blacksmithing video
Zak's restoration videos fun adventure
videos with me and the boys pretty much
anything you can do outdoors we do a
video about it thanks for watching guys
and if you want to see more great videos
from the outdoor boys YouTube channel
don't forget to thanks for watching we
hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see more great videos from
the outdoor voice youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video